shape-shifting telepathy laser vision
and magnetism they may be some of the
mutant abilities of the x-men but it
looks like 20th Century Fox's power is
making a shedload of money I'm Simon and
this is your mutant powered news update
the latest x-men movie Xmen apocalypse
is off to a hot start deadline reported
that the film pulled in a hundred 3.3
million dollars for its international
debut that counts box office receipts
for 75 markets apocalypse is pacing
ahead of the last film 2014's Days of
Future past which made a hundred million
dollars for its international opening
weekend in the same 75 markets the top
international market of x-men apocalypse
was the United Kingdom with 10.5 million
dollars followed by Mexico with eight
point six million dollars Brazil with
six point six million dollars Russia was
6.5 million dollars and France with 5.9
million dollars the movie is yet to open
in major international markets such as
China and Japan apocalypse comes to us
theaters on May 27th have you seen Xmen
apocalypse think it lives up to all the
hype let me know in the comments or come
find me on twitter i'm at the jagan or
thanks for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot